400 years ago my patriarchal ancestor
lawrence rutherford found our town
anyone see the resemblance i definitely
see it it's in the jaw
shoulders through the chest and probably
some other places
okay thank you i
am the steward of my family's legacy
that will resonate throughout history
and you have a museum you're gonna get
yours too
this is a ginormous casino but nobody
wants to help my cultural center
the only native artifacts in here are
those bangs
you seem smart i'm guessing lots of
college not ivy league
but so close it drives you crazy
northwestern
nathan i'm calling to request a response
to mayor chisenhall's decision to move
big larry i'm sorry what
the problem is not big larry it's the
road
this is the fifth time someone's crashed
into that statute it's a public safety
issue it's history deirdre you can't
change history unless you have a time
machine
and you don't because if you did you'd
go back and tell yourself not to buy
that laser
what i'm gonna get this town on my side
and i'm gonna transform my cultural
center
[Music]
this town has forgotten how to honor
their ancestors we focus on the problems
that are actually important
well big larry's important more
important than the opioid crisis
apples and oranges carla there's
something happening
in that town this is a story about
stories
damn the podcasting voice is
very manipulative
there's so much drama let's uh leave
them okay
no but i'm not done telling these people
why they're wrong and stupid
this is why it's not worth being friends
with white people no
you